the second law of thermodynamics tells
us that the entropy of the universe is
always increasing so the change in
entropy when for the universe when it
undergoes any process is always greater
than or equal to zero and we showed in a
previous video that it has a lot of
implications it's you know if you define
it well depend it's regardless of how
you define your entropy whether you
define entropy is equal to you know some
constant times the natural log of the
number of states your system could take
on or whether you define and change in
entropy to be equal to the heat added to
the system divided by the temperature
which is added either of these
descriptions combined with our second
law of thermodynamics tell us things
like when you have a hot body next to a
cold body so let's say this is t1 and
this then I have t2 over here that heat
will flow from the hot body to the cold
body and we show that mathematically in
the last video that heat will flow in
this direction now one of the commenters
on the last video said hey could you
cover Maxwell's demon and and I and I
will because it's it's it's a it's an
interesting thought experiment that
seems to defy this principle it seems to
defy the second law of thermodynamics
and it has a very tantalizing name
Maxwell's demon apparently though it was
not Maxwell who came up who called it a
demon it was Kelvin all these guys you
know they they they they're all they all
metal and everything so Maxwell's demon
so what's Maxwell's D and Max this is
the same Maxwell famous for Maxwell's
equations so he obviously dealt with a
lot of things he's actually also the
first person to ever generate a color
image so Danny and this was in the mid
1800s so all around fairly sharp
individual but what's Maxwell's demon so
when we say something has a higher
temperature than something else what are
we saying we saying we're saying that
it's average kinetic energy of its
molecules bumping around here that the
average kinetic energy of the molecules
here is higher than the average kinetic
energy of the molecules here none
I said it's average kinetic energy and
we've talked about this multiple times
temperature is a macrostate
we know that at the micro level all of
these molecules have different
velocities they're bumping into each
other transferring momentum to each
other you know this guy might be going
super fast in that direction this guy
might actually be going quite slow this
guy might be going super fast like that
that guy might be going quite slow it's
just a hodgepodge of things you could
actually draw a distribution if you knew
the microstates or of everything you
could you could actually draw a little
histogram we could say okay for T 1 T 1
my average let's say this is on the
Kelvin scale so you could say look my
average temperature is here but I have a
whole distribution of particles so let's
say this is number of particles number
of particles number of particles and I
won't put a scale there you'll get the
idea so I have a bunch of particles that
are at T 1 but I have some particles
that could be really close to absolute
zero I mean it would be very few but
it'd be very few and some numbers that
and then you have a bunch that are maybe
at T 1 and then you have a bunch of
particles that could have actually
kinetic energy higher than T 1 higher
than the average kinetic energy maybe
that's this one here maybe this guy down
here is this guy with barely any kinetic
energy maybe there's some guy who's
almost completely stationary who's you
know sitting right around there
someplace
so there's a whole distribution of
particles likewise this T 2 system right
here on average these molecules have a
lower kinetic energy but you know there
might be one particle here that has a
really high kinetic energy and you know
but most of them on average are lower so
if I were to draw the distribution of T
2 my average is lower my average kinetic
energy is lower but my distribution
might look something like this it can't
go backwards like that it might look
something like this oh I don't know
maybe it looks something like that let
me try a little different I'll make it
go just as high maybe it looks something
like that right so notice there there
are some molecules in T 1 that are below
the average kinetic energy of T 2 right
there are these molecules here these are
these slow guys right there these are
those slow guys
and notice there are some guys in t2
that have a higher kinetic energy than
the average in t1 so these are these
guys right here these are these guys
right here and so maybe so the fast guys
in t2 so even though t2 is quote unquote
colder it has lower average kinetic
energy there are some molecules if you
look at the micro Mac my microstate that
are actually moving around quite rapidly
and there are some molecules here that
are moving around quite slowly
so what Maxwell said is hey what if I
had my and he actually didn't use the
word demon but will use the word demon
because it makes it seem very
interesting and and and metaphysical on
some level but it really isn't what if I
had some dude let's call him the demon
with a little trapdoor here let me draw
it a little bit neater let me draw it a
little bit neater so I have so between
those two systems let's say let's say
that they're insulated let's say that
they're insulated they're separated from
each other so this is t1 where I have a
bunch of particles you know with their
different kinetic energies and then here
is t2 and I'm making them separated and
maybe they're connected only by this
little connection right here t2 these
guys have a slower kinetic energy and
what Maxwell his little thought
experiment was hey let me say that I
have some dude in charge of a door
that's right here maybe the doors right
here right and he has control over this
door and whenever a really fast particle
in t2 one of these particles over here
come near the door so let's say this guy
let's say this guy is flying let's say
that guy right there yes he's going
super fast he has super high kinetic
energy and he's just going perfectly for
the door so the demon says hey I see
that guy he's coming for the door he's
gonna lift the hatch he's gonna lift him
his hatch and he's gonna allow this
particle to get into that into t1 he's
gonna allow that particle to get into t1
so after he lifts a hatch that particle
will just keep going and it'll be in t1
and then when he sees a little and then
he closes the hatch again cuz
just wants the fast particles to go from
t2 to t1 and then when he sees a little
slow you know pokey little little
particle coming here one of one of these
guys down here he's like he opens a trap
door again and he allows that one to go
so then that guy shows up in here so if
he just kept doing that what's it gonna
look like at the end well at the end
you're going to segregate and it could
take a while
but you're going to segregate all the
slow particles on let me draw it I'll
make the boundary and brown cuz now it's
not clear which one is well we'll talk
about a little bit so that's the
boundary that's his door what's gonna
happen at the end all the fast particles
some of them are gonna be the original
fast particles that are in t1 right
there's some original fast particles in
t1 are gonna be still on this side of
the barrier but then all of the fast let
me draw make sure you don't get these
two confused um this is a separate
picture now all of the fast particles
from t2 are also gonna be stuck there
cuz that you know eventually they're all
gonna get close to that door if you wait
long enough so then this guy is also
gonna have a bunch of the uh what would
originally in in the t2 side of the of
the barrier they're also gonna be there
so you're gonna have a bunch of fast
particles likewise all the slow t2
particles are gonna be remaining on this
side of the barrier so these are the
slow guys and he's gonna he would have
let all the slow t1 I shouldn't even
call them t1 anymore that you know I
call him side one side one particles
here slow side one particles so what
just happened here what just happened
this was the hot body this was the cold
body though the second law of
thermodynamics would have told us that
heat would have gone from here to here
that their temperature should have
equalized to a certain degree so the the
hot body should get colder the cold body
should get hotter they should kind of
average out a little bit but using this
this little demonic figure what did he
do
he made the hot body hotter right now
the average kinetic energy here is even
higher he transferred he transferred all
of these high kinetic energy part
to that distribution so now that
distribution is going to look less you
ad so the way you could think about if
you transferred all of these guys to
this guy over here the the distribution
will now look something like let me see
if I can do it it'll look something like
that
41 instead of the old one and T 2 and he
took all the hot ones away all the cold
ones away from T 1 so these guys are
gonna disappear they're not gonna be
there anymore and he added them to t 2
he added them to t 2 so the distribution
of T 2 is gonna look like that and he
erased of course these from T 2 he took
all of these guys out of t 2 let me
erase this right here that was the old
distribution of T 1 so the T 2
distribution now looks something like
this now looks something like this so T
2 the at the new average it might be
something like here so this is our my
new T - and my new T 1 is gonna move to
the right a little bit the average is
gonna be high higher so this demon seems
to have violated the second law of
thermodynamics let me box off this right
here cuz it's my little diagrams are
overlapping this example shows that the
hot got hotter and the cold got colder
so you know Maxwell thought experiments
hey we violated the second law of
thermodynamics and this actually you
know it this was a conundrum for many
many years even and you know even in
this century people kind of hey you know
there's this something fudgy about here
or something not quite right and the
thing that's not quite right and I'm not
gonna prove it to you mathematically is
and it's kind of analogous to the
refrigerator example is to have
something here to have some dude some
dude perhaps he's a demon here pulling
this pulling this this this little door
when it's convenient when you know the
slope when the fast particles are going
from this side or the slow particles
going from that side in order for him to
do it correctly he's gonna have to keep
track of where all the particles are and
you need to keep track of particles I
mean these aren't these aren't balls
like you know macro balls these are
micro molecules or atoms he's gonna have
to either you know he's gonna have to
bounce light off of them or he's gonna
have to bounce electrons
microscope he's gonna have to keep track
of these gazillion particles that are
there and I mean think about there's a
lot of he might you know he might have
to have a super duper if it doesn't
occur in his head he might have to have
some kind of hard core computer
microchip you know that's that's
churning away and and this is this would
be actually you know for a computer to
do this this would be intensive
computation power and let your computer
run for a little bit and feel the
microchip this is generating a lot of
heat this is generating a lot of heat
his his his his bouncing off light or
whatever he's trying to bounce off off
the off of the different molecules to be
able to measure how fast they're going
that's also going to generate heat he's
gonna have to do work to do that he's
you have to measure everything there's a
lot of stuff that's going on that he's
gonna have to do so the current answer
is and it's it's not easy to prove
mathematically but the current answer is
if you actually wanted to build a demon
like this and probably in our world
today you would you'd use some type of
computer with some type of sensors to
attempt to do this and there are people
who who are who have attempted to do
this on some on some level this computer
and this whole system is going to
generate more entropy so this is going
to the doubt the delta s here is gonna
generate more entropy than the entropy
that's lost by taking the the cold
particles or by by making the cold side
colder and the hot side hotter so
Maxwell's demon I didn't do anything
rigorous here I didn't prove it to you
but Maxwell's demon it's an interesting
thought experiment because it gives you
a little bit more intuition about the
different macro States and microstates
and what happens at the molecular level
in terms of temperature and how you can
make a cold body colder and a hot body
hotter but the answer is it really isn't
a a paradox or anything like that that
the the when you think about the the
entropy of the entire system you have to
include the demon himself and if you
include the demon himself he's
generating more entropy every time he
opens that door and maybe there's some
energy required to open the door itself
but there's more energy required he
generates more entropy when he does all
of this than the entropy that might be
gained than the entropy that might be
lost when say for example one of these
slowpoke particles kind of just
traverses onto that side of the
barrier anyway I thought I would just
expose you to that because it's a really
neat thought experiment so I'll see you
in the next video